We have to realize something.
The debate about what to do with the country
over the next four to six weeks is not primarily
an empirical debate about science out in public.
It is not about flattening the curve.
It's not about looking at the case fatality
rate versus the infection fatality rate or
anything like that.
The current coronavirus debate happening in
popular culture is merely about who favors
a let them die approach and who does not.
And increasingly, we have to accept that Republicans
are making clear that they favor a let them
die strategy now.
So far, it doesn't seem like the governors
of the states with a lot of protests are being
influenced by the protests.
That's a good thing.
But it does appear that a lot of Republican
governors are starting to open things up.
I'll tell you which ones.
And it's important to understand that the
flattening of the curve doesn't directly save
lives in the sense that when you flatten the
curve, you still expect that over time, without
a vaccine, the same total number of people
would become infected.
It saves lives by spreading that same number
of cases out enough so that everybody can
get the best medical treatment possible because
the medical system isn't overwhelmed.
And by virtue of making sure resources are
available, it saves lives.
Imagine a million infections in a week versus
a million infections in a year.
Many more people will die with a million infections
in a week because many won't be able to actually
get the medical care that would be appropriate.
Either way, it's a million infections, but
we want to spread those out as much as possible.
Republicans are increasingly saying forget
about spreading it out, let it rip.
We are okay with letting them die.
Florida is starting to reopen beaches.
Now, you might think, well, Florida must have
the virus under control, right?
Very wrong.
Florida has nearly 30000 cases.
They're in a very clear plateau.
If you loosen guidelines during a plateau,
cases start going up again next week.
South Carolina is set to reopen beaches and
retail stores.
South Carolina, for now, fortunately, doesn't
have that many cases, by which I mean they
have about forty five hundred.
But we can expect those to start going up
once they reopen.
The Georgia governor camp says that businesses
like gyms, barbershops and hairstylists can
start opening this Friday, April 24.
Theaters, restaurants can follow on Monday,
April 27.
You've got Texas Republican Gov. Greg Abbott
saying businesses in the state would start
to reopen next week through a series of executive
orders.
Texas has about 20000 cases, so of course,
we can't hide in our houses forever.
But this has turned into essentially a referendum
on let them die because of the constitution
in some vaguely phrased terms or don't let
them die.
Now, during the 1918 flu pandemic, there were
instances of parts of the country ending quarantines
early and very quickly cases exploded.
Look at Philadelphia as one example.
We're already starting to see that.
Look at Kentucky, for example, on Sunday.
Kentucky had on a percentage basis their biggest
single day increase in cases to date.
And what's important to understand at this
point, we've gotta understand this, guys.
Even if the case numbers are low, the percentage
increases what you want to look at because
the term going viral comes from viruses and
a small number of cases can still be associated
with a large percentage increase.
And next thing you know, you've got a rapidly
increasing problem on your hands.
Now, protests during the week have continued
to increase and not surprisingly, we won't
know for 10 or 14 days.
That will also lead to a spike in cases.
We have Wisconsin, you might remember Wisconsin
voted on April 7th.
We are exactly 14 days from that election.
And after leveling off and starting to come
down.
Wisconsin is now starting to see an uptick
in cases.
We'll know the full scope of that within another
couple of days.
This stuff is real.
And, you know, Trump likes to call it the
invisible enemy.
It is invisible in a sense.
But you see the mass gatherings and then you
see the case numbers increase.
That's not invisible.
So the.
Chatterji from Republicans is let them die
to save the economy.
And we have to recognize that a widespread
pandemic will hurt the economy even more in
the long run.
There's a number of recent papers about this
that shouldn't surprise us, though, with health
care.
For decades, the Republican strategy has been
let them die.
We can give everyone health care, but it would
cost too much.
We can't afford to do that.
So people that could be saved from a medical
perspective are going to have to die because
we don't want taxes to go up or whatever bill
of goods goods they've managed to sell us.
So we're fighting the virus and we're fighting
the disinformation and we're fighting the
irresponsible actors.
There's a lot of fighting going on and the
numbers in another couple of weeks may look
very, very bad for some of these red states.
I hope not, but that's what the early indicators
are showing us.